ils ont 13 ans ou moins ils viennent des
quatre coins du monde
longtemps tour a accueilli le tournoi
nhn dédié aux championnats canadiens
il s'est arrêté il ya quelques années
mais l'esprit internationale demeure
avec cette nouvelle compétition qu'on a
voulu quand même continuer à offrir des
maillots aux enfants non conserver le
tournoi coupe du monde où chaque équipe
représente son pays
donc là sur la glace actuellement on a
les canadiens contre les français les
français de tours face au canada sur la
glace dans les vestiaires tonalité
multiples les représentants des clubs
slovène vont affronter l'équipe d'un
centre d'entraînement suisse composée
spécialement pour l'occasion
quand il y en avoir un maillot suis sûr
nos puits coq hardi professionnelle à la
télé puis on pense maintenant qu'on a
c'est qu'on se connaissait pas plus
maintenant je vous consulte et d'une
vraie équipe de copains on voulait être
premier mais on n'a pas du côté usa en
demi finale alors maintenant on objecter
troisième les hymnes nationaux avant les
rencontres tout se déroule comme pour
les pros
t'as pas l'être comme sa palette
d'accord pour qu'ils laissent pas
déborder rencontrer d'autres nations
découvrir d'autres styles de jeu toute
expérience est bonne à prendre dès le
plus jeune âge ont pas toujours quelle
canada c'est une supériorité au niveau
hockey mais c'est bien savoir que la
france la slovénie
la suisse commence à avoir des bons
joueurs qui le niveau de drogue
international devient de plus en plus mr
expérience sportive l'expérience humaine
l'équipe canadienne a passé une semaine
en france entre hockey et loisirs c'est
compétitif et un voyage mais moi je
trouvais plus que c'est un voyage parce
que on n'a pas vraiment fait bien dans
le tournoi
je suis comme des vacances mais
je crache ses spots trop compétitif le
speech unit belle expérience le pour la
petite histoire ce sont les états unis
qui l'ont emporté face aux français
danger chacun est prêt à revenir en
découdre l'an prochain